I got dudes in the industry I just want
to sit them down and make them do this
and ask them questions I'm with you bro
you're the smartest dude that ever lived
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with
high questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by LL Cool J he's a
two-time Grammy award-winning artist
hip-hop Trailblazer and recent inductee
to the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame which
really only tells half the story with
Decades of TV and film credits as well
from NCIS to toys to Any Given Sunday he
also founded Rock The Bells as media
company and Sirius radio channel which
of course celebrates classic hip-hop LL
Cool J welcome to the show thanks for
having me man what's going through your
head as you prepare to take on this
Gauntlet today I'm terrified B I don't
know what's happening this is all these
hot so I didn't expect all this is a lot
of different brands labor I I kind of
I've seen the show but I didn't really
like realize the you know what I mean
yeah the scale of it when it meets you
away yeah especially me because this is
like exactly what I'm avoiding at the
restaurant like like I'm moving right
past this section
foreign
that's hot enough me
that's hard enough right there like I
could go home
oh man
well God damn
foreign
that's stage one that's stage one we're
in for one today we are and with Fallas
I'm a little hungry and I'm tempted to
go for it a little more but I'm gonna
yeah I'm gonna ease and taste it we'll
face it we'll Pace it okay so you're
just coming off the Grammys were you
introduced and performed in the
star-studded tribute to hip-hop's 50th
Anniversary right is someone who's won
multiple Grammys hosted the show on five
different occasions where did last
Sunday's performance rank amongst your
most treasured Grammy memories it's
probably uh
the most enjoyable one of the most
enjoyable I mean I've had other moments
hosting just Purely Hosting that were
amazing as well but as as an artist I
mean this was like by far the most fun
for me I mean being on stage with with
Rakim and Public Enemy and salt and
pepper and Grandma's a flash smelly
mouth scorp Raheem
I just want people to know that you know
for years hip-hop has been being served
in a brown paper bag a greasy brown
paper bag I want people to I wanted it
to be served on a silver platter and you
know thankfully it was I was able to you
know make a huge contribution Quest love
did a wonderful job curating Jesse did
an amazing job producing you know
getting making sure the production was
right and you know me just sewing things
together making sure things are right
and really helping to mold it and make
it what it is and and I think it turned
out to be something real special for
hip-hop
Shaquanda and she ain't gonna come out
she ain't gonna jump out the curtains or
nothing all right
yeah okay
[Music]
still got our feet yeah I'm okay here we
go I'm okay there we go my tongue is
like
attentive right now you know head on a
sweater like yeah
my tongue is waiting for it it accepts
you right now like you got when you're
on offense you got to keep your head on
the swivel looking out for interception
yeah but if there's an interception
that's how my tongue feels right now
it's just like you know that alert my
tongue has a chubby
you know it's not all the way there but
it's you know what I mean it's ready
it's ready here for you a little tongue
chubby right now okay so we had Queen
Latifah on the show she reminisced about
performing that LA roller rinks turn
music venues like Skateland and rolled
on Wheels yeah what role did places like
the rink in North Jersey play in your
own hip-hop origin story oh man the rink
was incredible I mean um that was one of
the first places I ever played at was
the rink
because that was back then when we
didn't have music videos so I only had
like I need a beat out with the rink
that that built a Sheffield punch drunk
right now
um it's like you know I mean the show
that's the speed bag in my lips right
now my lips has been speed bagged I
can't even focus me
um
um yeah the rink so I I went out there
and uh [__] it man I don't know what I'm
talking about whatever whatever it was
whatever I was gonna say it was gonna be
smart and provocative and introspective
right what do you remember about hearing
I need a beat for the first time at the
game room on Farmers Boulevard I mean it
was an amazing feeling to like imagine
if your dream was like a big giant
bubble right and it was coming towards
you and you had the ability to pull it
in
and it's your dream
so you have a hand in it and it's your
dream so I'm out there I'm staring at
the the ground you know I had rain
earlier that day
but you know I'm out there and this dude
comes up to me and he's like yo that's
you on the radio and I remember I
remember staring out the street the
street lights it was dark and I was like
yeah I know I like that
you know the the the light was
glistening like diamonds off the street
it was like it was a unbelievable moment
I'm right there with you I'm right there
with you and if you're right there with
me I am are you ready to move on here
yeah this is the sauce number three
let's do it so this is the donuts cadejo
here the donuts cadejo
foreign
don't ask good day hoe
it's getting hot in here getting hot in
here
getting hot in here
shot shot shot shot shot shot
you know me God damn right there right
there
Factor fiction and animatronic shark's
grasp onto your left leg almost cause
you to drown on the set of Deep Blue Sea
thousand percent true facts 100 facts I
was on the set
you know what I mean I was probably
number 479 on the call sheet
and uh you know
I was you know in the middle of a take
and uh lunch and the guy holding the you
know the little the little joystick you
know pastrami you know and they just you
know broke they just bailed on me and
there I was just like it was like real
and they said oh and they gave me this
little breathing thing this little
breathing apparatus like something like
this you know and you blow out and then
breathing I blew out breathed in all
water took it to another level but I
ended up struggling getting out and when
I got out climbed out there was one dude
sitting there with a cigarette like
that's how it happened
you know what I mean so it was cool
Los Calientes Verde foreign
[Music]
going through it
Going Back to Cali
Caliente
[__]
going back to Caliente Caliente
damn B what are some of the biggest
difference in navigating the music
industry versus Hollywood like I don't
think it's a coincidence that the
hip-hop icons have had this enduring
Everlasting Legacy on the big screen
also happened to be some of the most
business savvy
um
discipline equals freedom
you know the music industry man is a
wonderful business and it can be a
wonderful business
but the reality is not many people are
very disciplined
you make it to the gold chain now what
you make it to the diamond neck brace
now what you know what I'm saying and so
it's the discipline
and the guys that you see that are
successful and the women that you see
that are successful to people that you
see that are successful they're
disciplined like I always tell my staff
and my team it's like it's corny and it
sounds cheesy but it's true ego is not
your amigo
you know what I'm saying humility is a
superpower
okay
this right here Brooklyn Deli ghost
pepper sauce
[Music]
yeah different kind of
yeah yeah
I'm [__] yeah
oh no level that [__] you're touching
dude you walk in the house that [__] put
you in a headlock [__] sit the [__] down
I run this I run this [__]
wow yeah holy mackerel yeah
[Music]
going in
all right all Cool J we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram we're doing a deep dive on our
guest Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context okay so
we'll pull the picture up over here on
the monitor you just tell us the bigger
story okay what's the origin story
behind meeting Rick Rubin for the first
time at his NYU dorm room 14 years old I
was trying to get a record deal and um I
went you know what I'm saying to a
record store called record exposure I
used to go and buy either buy or if I
had the money or just Barack copy now in
the addresses of any song that looked
like it was hip-hop or was or I knew was
hip-hop so I would either buy them or
write them down and send demos out and I
did that for like two years and I
finally bought it yours by Tila rock it
was um it had Def Jam Productions the
logo was on on the label was StreetWise
party time and they had the Def Jam logo
I called Rick I didn't know it was a
dorm room at the time but I used to call
them all the time
every day every day every day every day
and um you know Rick you get the tape
yet nope call him next day Rick you get
the tape yet nope Rick you get the tape
yet and finally add Rock from the
Beastie Boys he heard my tape and he
played it for Rick and then Rick called
me and you know the rest is history here
we are like you know hall of fames and
Grammys and it's crazy man first time I
met him I said when I walked in I was
like oh [__] you wreck he said yeah I
said I thought you was black he said
cool so he's black dude he's like yo
what's up it's Rick I'm like I thought
you know Rick I was expecting Frankie
Crocker to come out that [__]
you know what I mean you know you know
you know I mean I expected you know dog
Cornelius you know me I thought John
Cornelius was going to come downstairs
bro
mushroom Mayhem mushroom Mayhem are
these mushrooms gonna make all these
colors become Vivid is this a there's
only kind of Mayhem we talk about
there's only one way to tell but I'm
keeping my fingers crossed
that it will happen yeah
oh
foreign
[Music]
this is wow wow mushroom Mayhem go ahead
now go ahead mushroom oh [__] that's the
new rapper for you little mushroom the
mushroom Mayhem yeah I like that that
sounds like a hit get a mullet cut
little mushroom Mayhem a little dude
with a mullet
do you remember what felt like your
first like big money show like do you
remember your first ten thousand dollar
show or your first thousand dollar show
or I mean
the first show for 300 was big money
yeah you're kidding me like what what
yo listen let me tell you something
first of all I started when I was 16.
all I wanted at that time was a VCR a
gold chain and some some sneakers
my first check that I ever got that
would to me was a lot of money was fifty
thousand dollars the first thing I did
was buy my mother a car and then I gave
my mother like
I don't know 10 or 8 Grand or something
and I took the rest and I just remember
all my [__] being gone and my mother's
still having the eight grand and I'm
like I'm like
I didn't really understand what happened
here you know I mean he was just like
what happened but um
you grew up and you learn and get a
chicken wing if I need one you know what
I'm saying I'm doing okay I'm blessed so
it's all good all right all right this
next one uh-huh is the dreams of calypso
here
shout out to Harry Belafonte
[Music]
oh my God bro hey damn
that is so crazy it's like a like a
little aluminum foil rolls is blooming
in my throat that is
way to put it a beautiful way to put it
wow
go for it go for it
oh [__]
I don't even like milk like that he
needs your milk
any port in a storm any port in a storm
ah no I ain't going that far with you
oh wow
would call you see that dangly thing in
my throat this [__] is that dangly thing
in your throat carty this right here you
know this is crazy so you signed a Def
Jam in 1984 and you've successfully
navigated the notoriously treacherous
music industry alongside some of the
biggest Titans in the game so if you'll
humor me what I want to do is just a
thought association game right hit you
with a rap Tycoon and you just give me
the first couple of thoughts that come
to your mind okay Leo Colin smart
I think he's smart I think he's um
he's only going to do what he has to
love you Leo he's only going to do what
he has to be Chris lady brilliant
brilliant guy going too soon
it's my friend loved him miss him
ahead of his time good guy
oh my God
that [__] is in the pipes yeah
clogged pipes God damn where's little
industry I just want to sit them down
and make them do this and ask some
questions I'm with you bro you're the
smartest dude that ever lived with this
[__] this [__] is crazy nobody's smarter
than you with this [__]
what's the name of this one this is the
bomb Beyond insanity
yeah probably for the best yeah that was
good that's good
for the first time a calm in the room
oh
and I am telling you
I'm not going yo this [__] is yeah
yo
crazy they must be crazy military
technology to make that [__]
that [__] is crazy oh man brother man
I can't sit still
you know I can't say hold on don't even
talk don't understand you're just gonna
chill I'm just gonna chill
[__] that's wow
God
oh you need your milk oh
yeah give me some ice cream
ah bringing it in bringing it in
God damn I'm glad you came with the ice
cream I'm glad you came with the ice
cream
oh God damn oh no I know
God damn
oh
oh God
whoa
I'm starting to cry out this
[__]
that's the best ice cream in the world I
know and never hit butter
yo bro moments like this I know I know I
it's getting hotter it's [__] it's
increasing grows and gross grow
holy [__] yo
you gotta be [__] kidding me bro holy
[__] God damn it just be careful around
the eyes God damn I know
I know
it was like I'm damn near like a
crackhead mode right now oh no no
disrespect this [__] like no yeah I feel
like it's like the crackhead [__] right
now I really I do feel like everything
crackhead levels are ridiculous this
[__] is
yo come on man are you serious
holy [__] wow wow wow
I know that you're a ice cream
connoisseur like what do you think's the
goat ice cream flavor
ah
yo my [__] lips are hot yeah
everything everything
holy Mack
depends on the mood
you know neapolitan's always a mean
cookies and cream is good you know
vanilla chocolate and strawberry you're
not going you know if you put them them
three together you you know a couple of
bananas some hot fudge syrup you know I
made some of them strawberries you know
what I mean [__]
no that God
got to love that
that was so crazy it's still hot right
and what's really foul about it it's
pink it's pink it's pinball machine hot
in other words it's hot over there and
it's hot over here it stops over here
it's hot down here it stops down there
it's hot over here it's hot up there
it's hot over here it's hot in the back
it's hot in the front it like you know
what I mean yeah it's ricocheted it's
Ricochet yeah yeah wow are you ready to
move on to the next one I'm ready baby
so this is Taco Vibes only Taco Vibes
only okay
yo I'm I'm I'm you know I gotta I'm
taking the small yo will you come on
this show take small bites me don't even
think about going hard
there you go oh come on man but not like
the last one not like the last one look
at me
that [__] is like
it's like [__] episodic at this point
it's episodic television it's like this
is the [__] next episode it like you
know it has a recap yeah then it started
last week or BMF but remember remember
that first one remember I remember
remember the bomb and how you're feeling
not this one not as bad not as bad right
I'm just wondering about like you know
the real damage the act two yeah next
week's episode no no yeah I'm I'm really
concerned about that right now
what is pink cookies in a plastic bag
getting crushed by buildings mean
I don't know that was high when I wrote
it
you know what I mean I know what you
mean I
um you know I was um
I mean you know I have no idea bro I
don't know that the high as a
[__] man that [__] is just what
it is man I was on the phone with some
girl she said what are you doing I said
I'm just sitting here thinking about
pink cookies and a plastic bag get
crushed by the buildings she said what I
said you know what that's a song I'll
call you back
I say yo Molly let's go downstairs
with downstairs
all right I'll call Jay
whoa look at you
you know they say tradition is peer
pressure from dead people yeah yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you know okay you want to do a
little dab on them huh
I did not mean for that guy yeah yeah
yeah that's too much too much
yeah yeah dude yeah smart yeah okay well
what a run and what a ride hey
Cheers Cheers
all right
I know I can see the face already I know
I know
oh my God and don't worry
because a nice big wind up on this one
okay
we came we saw we ate
we conquered
and you know you're one of hip-hop's
great ambassadors from the music that
shifted the landscape to rock the bells
which continues to honor classic hip-hop
to your most recent Grammy performance
which of course was a toast to the 50th
Anniversary so to close things out with
your brain on fire your mouth Ablaze how
would you best distill what hip-hop has
meant to you like what is Your Love
Letter to the genre well I'll tell you
like this first of all
you know just because the way I grew up
and where I was raised if I wasn't doing
hip-hop
you know it had been you know
either the military bank robbery or drug
dealing
one of them three
when I was a little kid when I was in my
20s it was about me taking my shirt off
and making it about me now it's about
looking out at the culture and elevating
all of these artists and making sure
that this culture is celebrated the way
it should be and the way I believe it
should be and that's been that's my
life's Mission with rock the bells
that's why Rock The Bells is so
important to me and is is has become the
go-to company for all people who oh [__]
my mouth is High
um oh God I can't even get my spill I
had the elevator pitch down bro it's
over Rock The Bells is hot [__] you know
what I mean listen just check it out go
to the.com check it out she's hot you
know what I mean we're not corny we're
not it ain't Dusty as fly
[__] it Mike drop and look at you oh
Cool J taking on the wings of breath and
living to tell the tale now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life all right
well right now
um I have a new album coming out this
year a new record produced by Q-tip of A
Tribe Called Quest Rock The Bells as a
company as a culture company we have
content Commerce and experiences you
know I'm saying that we're doing it so
that's what I'm doing God damn coming up
is hot I was hot my man appreciate you
bro
I appreciate you man wow that was crazy
B wow crazier than you thought it would
be are you kidding me hell yeah that
[__] was [__] double Straight Jackets
double Straight Jackets man
God damn
hot ones fans breaking news the three
and one boneless bites challenge is back
for a limited time you can put your
taste buds to the test against some of
our most iconic flavors the classic Los
Calientes and the peak of heat Apollo
but don't fret hot ones fans even when
the three-in-one challenge leaves the
freezer aisle you can still pick up your
favorite flavor of hot ones boneless
bites visit hotoneschallenge.com for
more information on products and to find
a store near you because it's time to
bring the Heat home